we're gonna live for going live we're
going live it says we are live alright
hello everybody and welcome to two round
table with the stream team I was
listening to the ironist podcast this
morning so I almost did the ramble from
that one on accident so uh how's
everybody doing we're doing a you know a
little a year in review with the our
fellow stream team members just to kind
of see how things were going for the
past year what we're anticipating for
next year it's gonna be a nice and easy
one I appreciate everybody for stopping
in sorry for starting late I had some
problems connecting the stream to allow
us to begin so we have MJ here today
how are you MJ doing good how about
yourself
not too bad hanging in there had a crazy
day at work but I'm happy that
everything that's kind of us moved over
and I'm here tonight with everybody so
uh l-boogie howhow are you doing I'm
pretty good still getting over this cold
yeah yeah when you told me last week you
you like I can't count on top I'm sick
I'm just like no I know like I know my
voice is like so much worse and yeah it
wouldn't have been it you apparently got
my cold through the internet I'm sorry I
feel like everybody is getting this cold
like even people in the Seattle or sick
right now my boss in New York City was
sick it's crazy it's probably going
around right now it's that time of year
yes that time of year everyone travels
look and they take the sickness from
city to city yep yep and me working at
an airport is not pretty so it's like
everyone is just there so it's like a
disease I don't even want to go in the
terminals to work material you know
think about is that there was if there
was ever outbreak you're getting it
first
oh thanks for the reminder greatly
appreciate it I'm gonna walk around with
one of those masks like they do and was
it was in China or Japan yeah yeah yeah
but I think they do for smog reasons not
for us what's going on doubled TJ what's
how are you doing
Slayer how you doing uh sorry for the
little late nasai go saying we're happy
we're going on we're going on here
so yes it's so Ellen MJ so you know how
how how things been with you for this
year with with your gaming and your you
know with your streaming lives and your
you know your your like gaming lives
MJ wants you go ahead and start us off
so for the beginning Lear it started out
pretty strong and then after that it
started to go kind of downhill because
the school and I didn't really have time
to play anything mm-hmm
but now that I'm on break I've been
playing a lot and catching up on games
that have been like warning deployer
excellent excellent I want I want to get
I want to get into the games but I want
to I just wanted to hear like you know
how you kind of like progress through it
throughout the year so when you uh when
you ended up like getting to like school
like you just focus on school or did you
like kind of like squeeze in games while
you were going or was it kind of like
just again up and down or um dependent
on the time like sometimes it'd be like
oh I really do want to play games but I
didn't really have time to stream
because I'd have to like set everything
up yeah like if I were to play it'd be
like having somebody over and playing on
the big screen and the lobby of my dorm
hall yeah like six TVs were you calling
people out you'd be like hey let's play
and then you just like wreck them like
it was like playing pool in a Bioshock
together cuz my favorite game oh you
well you know that there's a rumor that
there's another yeah it's gonna be nice
it's gonna be good
so Elwha how about you how was how's the
beginning of the year for you I don't
even know like if I made a goal or
anything I just been you know and join
streaming trying to get a little better
each week and whatnot and I just looked
at I'm only 25 away from a thousand
followers I'll make sure so yeah I just
try to do
my little giveaways give back to the
community that supports me and whatnot
and seems to be working out excellent
are you doing your the gleam giveaways
and stuff like that yeah yeah
and the gwg podcast and weren't you girl
once weren't you ladies yes we are doing
a giveaway so we're doing a giveaway for
a 60 dollar gift card for Christmas
so basically somebody can get a game for
Christmas from us from the Roman
beginning podcast if no one else is
getting them something oh when you get a
sec just drop that link in chat so
lovers here make sure that you go go in
there and you get you know you go in on
that that's the rate it's fantastic and
so it's a good thing it's great that you
you know you you are giving back big for
that because it's I feel that that's
that's one of the best feelings when you
have those followers that are you know
in your channels or you know the subs or
embers in your case like you can end up
giving giving them the you know right
the love bag yeah because like me I'm
right for me personally I'm able to buy
my games you know so if people donate to
me I like to be able to give it right
back out you know yeah I love that
that's that's that's a big thing in my
in my in my heart I appreciate it so and
I and I know that others do too so you
uh you really didn't have any goals this
year that you kind of like I want to hit
this amount of people I want to want to
do this XYZ but you kind of felt that
like you wanted to make sure that you
were streaming more you were playing
yeah more consistently I have like a
schedule like so many people were
telling me to do and just be more
consistent so that's pretty much what
I've tried to do yeah that's good that's
good and do you feel like you have to
achieve that for most of the year I
should say not mid-year yeah most of the
year you know obviously I moved in stuff
like that but I think that for the most
part I've tried to implement that and
been pretty successful
and I've you know you find you know we
have people that are on Twitter and
stuff like that the follow us right
where people but and I'm starting to get
some newcomers coming in especially with
playing Call of Duty destiny and stuff
like that I think people or um you know
always like to see a female that can
play a little bit you know I'm not like
best alone
you could whoop some heinie alright and
crucible yeah I was like popping awfully
cool
oh I remember you uh you're going after
kognito apart in the beginning of the
year I remember that post yeah yeah
because he was like in it was crazy he
like we were playing and then I saw he
was like in our match and I'm like is
this Lord God needle like this same guy
or somebody different but yeah it was
him listen I was trying to kill him the
entire game you had your objective it
was like kill right yeah forget what the
game is selling me I don't need to carry
anything English objectives objectives
my objectivism yeah for me it was I I
wanted to kind of do a couple of
different things I wanted to to make
sure that I had a head merchandise I
wanted to make sure I wanted to give
bless you I wanted to make sure that I
was giving back to my community and I
wanted to produce like a set schedule
and sit with it as much as I could and
those were like the three things I kind
of wanted to do and it was for the most
part it was very difficult in the
beginning because you know it takes a
little bit of time to kind of get used
to it but by the by March right before
we went to PAX East I was able to get
some basic merch out and then by mid
year I ended up getting a bunch of
Murchie a bunch of shirts hats things
like that and then
I'm doing another small wave the end of
this year because I feel like doing
March you kind of have to have it geared
towards what you're playing and like in
the beginning of the year I was playing
one game in the middle of year I was
playing another game in the end of the
year I've been playing another game so
it's kind of like it's kind of had to
flow and then I was able to keep myself
scheduled for probably like 90% of the
year except for when I was in I'm here
but other than that it's been pretty
good and I've I think it's been pretty
nice to see the growth like I like I
always say i streamed there before i
come here to make sure everything that's
kind of running smooth and like i had
about 9 or 10 people in the in my chat
which is like a big growth from the
beginning of the year because you know
because it was pretty low at the
beginning of the year because it's like
the holiday season and then you know you
get I got a little bit of it from
division and then I kind of went down
because of Warcraft and I kind of what's
going back up now again for tarkov so
it's kind of like we're flows and it
kind of it's been working out pretty
good for me
so so l what games would have you been
playing this year that kind of like you
enjoyed and what you've been streaming
and what your liking for this year this
past year um so prime my game of the
year has to be Star Wars I grew it was
just really good right it was fantastic
it's a great game I think yeah I think
I'm Jay I didn't you say you started
playing it also this this past week yeah
I started it the day came out except I
didn't really have a lot of time to plan
for a bigger first mission and they just
sort of liked it and I'm actually loving
it yeah yeah it's it's great so what
else oh I really liked Call of Duty as
well yeah the story just like really got
to me because it's really I guess
accurate
as far as how it is from military and
the stories I've heard from my guy
friends that you know we're in theater
mm-hmm so I loved how they did that and
then destiny you know it's like a
love-hate relationship
yeah so that's like my ongoing game of
the year I guess I would say yeah um
what are Indies that I played this year
well there's one game I'm playing it
right now and it's pretty cool what is
this lonely mountains down here oh I saw
it on game path so it's like there where
you're like BMX riding down like a heel
like a mountain right right and you
gotta like steer a certain way you know
it's not I know it sounds easy but it's
not easy at all right if you think about
those games were like remember those
phone games where you could accelerate
really fast but then you would like fall
all weird yeah so it kind of reminds you
of something similar to that and then I
was telling a MJ about a few games and
game pass oh and outer worlds I never
finished outer worlds overcook - I love
playing it with the kid oh and it's
super hard like it's not easy at all I
don't know if you gather I'm sorry he
said a overcooked screwed up my
achievements I beat the first level in a
game in the achievement that was worth
of 1.0 never even yeah you gotta love
games to do that disappointing games I
guess I'll have to say it was a jump
horse that's kind of upset about that
yeah I I agree with you I was looking
forward to a really really good fighting
game this year and I felt like there was
like jump force was going to be it
because they have so much potential
because it's anime and you literally do
right right and it seems super cool and
there's the kind of fall on its face and
then you can be mad at me but the
division disappointed me I I so I I was
very happy with it for probably six
months after it came out and I I played
it every day and I loved it and then it
was just it kind of it kind of fell with
a heavy heart for me because it's always
like one of my favorite games I want to
I want to play and I want to always play
it and I want I mean I made a whole
really good great but group of friends
with that game and the the amount of
content that they gave it's pretty sad
and they did this change to all the gear
this past patch and I thought it was
going to be great and I was gonna be
like yes good revitalize the game yeah
yeah
and it didn't really do that much and
then they added hardcore and I was like
oh yeah this is great hardcore and then
I was like I'm not gonna ever do this
because if my character dies I'm gonna
be so pissed off because right there's
so many little bugs in this game like
not being able to heal or not drop in
your alive I was like I'm probably never
going to do that and then they talked
about doing like the next raid and then
they pushed it to next year which I can
understand
but then they also stated in the last
day that they've saved the game that
they're gonna end up revamping the whole
entire talent system and I'm like I'm
not gonna grind now and I have to grind
again before the rate comes out because
who knows when the rate comes out so I'm
I'm a little disappointed with the the
longevity progress I can understand why
they're doing it but at the same time
it's like you had this great game and
then you shot you're like you you didn't
learn from break point wildlands that
was terrible yeah great point wildlands
pretty much was is the same games that
the vision just
like one shot kills so why are you gonna
end up like putting this game out
that's literally against the same game
like the same thing as division and it's
just then they did it again and I was
just like then the whole entire game was
was a flop and I'm just I'm just shaking
my head going you you you should really
cut your losses here and go back to the
division where all these people could be
doing a lot better and you could have
had the raid done you could have had
survival placed in division which
everyone wants and you could have made
this game thrive just like Destiny's
house and I'm I'm just I'm so I'm so
angry and bitter about it as you as you
can tell I mean you have a right to be
though like we've kind of like really
invested in those games right yeah
and it's like I don't know I guess you
know what are the other huge flops of
this year would be anthem buddy huh it's
[ __ ] five dollars oh yeah it's so
ditz I can't even name stretch Oh if you
know what the game isn't trash that's
the worst part about it yeah the problem
is it's so much potential it's just like
exactly it just it falls flat on its
face because they didn't have the
backing or the content to continue just
like division and it it was like you you
have so much you could do and I know Chi
Basu is is huge on and can't wait for it
and loves it but it's just like like I'm
just I'm so sad thinking about it
because I want I want to like it and I
want to play it and it'll I'm sorry
we're putting out like something to make
the game better for free well they put
those storms and the Cataclysm storms
but like even the Cataclysm storms if
you watched the the cuts from like what
they said that was going to be an e3 and
what it is now it's like the difference
is
it looks like are walking through a
hurricane is essentially what the video
at e3 looked like and then if you look
like it now it looks like a dusting like
you got a little wind and like a little
bit of rain but it's not really
obviously taking the big players off of
the game obviously didn't make sense to
me I'm sorry that story and anthem like
I played through the entire thing it
didn't make any sense to me
the story had a very fluid story and an
Hadley bright I even though it was short
I thought it was a pretty decent story
but I felt like they could have done a
lot more in the end now they just have
like legendaries dropping like like it's
nothing really
microtransactions either like I don't
care like if it's you know cosmetics you
know that's for me to decide if I'm
gonna spend my money on cosmetics but um
they weren't even doing cosmetics right
usually $10 for green like no so [ __ ]
it's just green yeah sad dialogue and
like you know permissions which one the
girl at the market he's the last man on
earth and much other cartoon isn't so
what right right I totally I totally
miss thought like crazy stories and then
like she was done like super quick and I
she was like one of the most interesting
characters there suicide was there it
was there anything that was there
anything else no I had my MJ cuz that
did a lot of talking uh uh MJ what about
you was there anything like that you
kind of was disappointed with what you
enjoyed so yes straining so what does
that it disappoint it or happy oh you
got the baby you've bought the baby you
know
so with the death stranding I'm like two
hours in the game it's a little slow I
know somebody who's working out who
worked on the game so I mean so far it's
not horrible I mean it it is a little
slow but I like it I know some people in
ILP are not a huge fan of it yeah some
all yeah
also I've been playing a little bit of a
Pokemon sword mm-hmm
I think I'm like two hours of them it's
pretty fun yeah Borderlands I beat the
sheer I thought it was pretty good
not my favorite I still love to I picked
up some games on Black Friday
you think Borderlands 2 is better than
three I think so really gory
I like the gameplay of three but the
story of two I started playing Bioshock
cuz I've never played that series first
one was amazing second one I'm like
halfway through right now it's pretty
hard game Super Mario maker - played a
little bit of that I haven't had too
much time mm-hmm
I picked up Super Monkey Ball on Black
Friday it was like 30 bucks it's pretty
damn hard that's all sometimes where I
just want to like throw the controller
because of how mad I get I there's been
times when playing Star Wars falling
order I want to toss my controller bring
a mana Madonn I beat it in the day I was
playing with the buddy because once you
buy it you get a buddy pass yeah so me
and my buddy were playing this yesterday
I should have stream very game you would
have loved it because of how scared I
was gonna I'm scared yeah that's when I
think jump scares I think MJ you know um
another game I picked up was plants vs.
zombies there is not a lot about this I
think it just randomly dropped which
plants vs. zombies
not a lot of people know about it battle
royal yeah it's not a battle royale it
has like a campaign it's like garden
warfare if you've ever played any of
those oh okay
I picked a breakpoint cuz it was on sale
for 20 bucks 20 bucks it's only been
helpful like two months yeah
Best Buy had it for 20 bucks oh my god
come on October beginning of October yep
and then on Black Friday also picked up
overwatch for the switch okay have you
played it yet on switch I like it
some people don't like it but I like it
because on campus have Wi-Fi all over
the campus so I mean pretty much play
overwatch anymore oh that's what
suppressor and then of course following
order so was it the the really nice part
about the having the switch and having
those abilities to travel with your
games it's just it's perfect and then
being able to do that with overwatch it
kind of just adds to more of the you
know the the growth of the overwatch
franchise and then adding overwatch too
which is pretty much like a glorified
matte pack it's gonna be really nice to
see over the next year how how the game
is gonna grow what do you what do you
what do you think was like a bad game
this year that you kind of like we're
looking at or your most unhappy game
that you were playing for I don't know
was that this year last year that game
um trend thing I don't know I haven't
had a lot of time to play yeah so I
wasn't necessarily disappointed so much
because I haven't really played a lot
yeah so you what you were more just
happy that you're actually had some time
to play because you've had such such as
yeah anthem anthem is your unhappy
unhappy game here so so for myself I
mean you guys probably hit all the same
same same truck boxes as me this past
year for her games it's like all I
really did was like I was saying before
was I played division world Warcraft and
escape from tarkov on PC and those games
pretty much have been keeping me going I
played anthem in the beginning of the
year also I was trying to do that also
and it it seems like anthem was a flop
division was good in the beginning and
then a flop and then Warcraft the game
had had a really good large group of
people playing it but it it was
considered a flop in the world of
warcraft two eyes so it was kind of like
it almost like I was stumbling all year
for a good content for a game and then I
ended up I've been playing escape from
tarkov and it is one of the the best
realistic shooters I've I've encountered
I think it's all it's very realistic and
it's probably something I'm going to be
playing for a while which is which is
nice but it's it's good it's a good game
good quality game but I I mean like you
were saying I was very disappointed in
in Division I like we like you heard my
rants and anthem I mean I I wish they
could have done more it's kind of sad I
wanted to get some more Destiny's time
in this year and it's just and I just I
knew I wasn't gonna be able to so I
never picked it up and the same thing
with Borderlands 3 like everyone was
playing it and it looks really really
good and I loved those first Russian
shooter vibes and I just I was like
there's no way I'm gonna have time for
it but and there was some there's some
uh you know indie games mixed in like
flotsam and other game set
developers wanted us to play on the
channel which I which I thought was good
got that dust at me I played a little
bit of that over the summer or actually
I should say a lot a lot of it over the
summer yeah get yourself all prepped and
ready I remember that I don't I haven't
played destiny in a long long time now
mm-hmm cool I kind of stopped is that
the thing so so what do you what are you
kind of excited for for next year of
course cyberpunk yeah it was this game
by Looby and I haven't really heard them
talk too much about it anymore were
there like skating around are you
talking about watch the rollerblades
yeah no I'm talking about the room with
the girl and the monkey guy and they're
in space
Oh oops it's like it was already a game
apparently yeah there's the first
version of it I'm blanking on the name
um yeah I think because of all of the
fault like the trips and falls they've
had this past year a lot of those games
have been put on backlog a lot of them
because yeah they were supposed to come
up with watch those lesions they pushed
that back to this year they right yeah I
was really looking forward to that and
it was good Beyond Good and Evil thank
you Jonathan B thank you very much
Beyond Good and Evil that was the
original was the name of the new one or
no no Beyond Good and Evil is the next
one and good and evil was the first one
I think that's what it was
so yeah that's what that was one game
that I was looking forward to also I
really like movie game
[Music]
I don't know now I'm looking forward to
see you like what's gonna happen with
the Xbox series it's and you know what
they're gonna bring to the table as far
as launch games so this III is gonna be
crazy
get out here I don't know get out there
I don't know it all depends upon timing
vacation things like that money I have I
have a lot of factors for me because it
isn't cheap but I'm gonna I'm definitely
gonna I'm thinking about it but you want
it you want to laugh I figure you'll
appreciate this because you know cuz if
your your xbox love you know what the
new Xbox looks like to me and every
single time I see it I think of it well
then the Sims they have computers oh
yeah and there's square boxes and they
look exactly like that and I laugh every
time I see it I'm thinking that they
took that right from The Sims like Sims
way you know people were like upset with
the fact that it looks like a tower
which then people were like oh it looks
like a you know a real tower but you can
tell that it's not like a square my god
not square a rectangle yeah yeah I don't
know who looks like a PC and they're
from pcs like so I don't know it's not
part of a stretch for me but yeah but I
think that they probably developed on
that because of heat yes I mean like
yeah I know that that's why they did
that because it it will get way too hot
I mean it's just why many many PCs that
you see now they're in the same shape
yep you know because how else are you
gonna be able to get something that
small with that much power you know
exactly I agree I agree
are you uh are you gonna be a first
adapter to it are you gonna put your
pre-order on of course oh good good good
yeah I saw Game Stop is already taking
pre-orders but they have it it's already
scarlet and I'm like okay update your
info oh so is there anything else to
look forward to to actually your answer
today cuz I've been a little out of the
loop because I've been really busy with
real life stuff going on
is there anything going on with physical
with that ps5 did they actually launch
the picture of what it looks like I
don't believe so I saw that there was at
one rumor which it does look like
something they would make yeah that's
because I'm like I keep looking with the
Twitter feed and I'm just like is that
really what they're gonna do is that not
like I get confused but I get easily
confused sometimes so with some of the
stuff coming on Twitter like what's just
false which is real because it's just so
much information being thrown at you
from three different directions you're
like which is real which is not mm-hmm
so excellent is there any is there any
game so you're kind of intrigued about
for ps5 oh no really
it's funny because I'm looking forward
to the Last of Us - and I've heard it
like my whole thing was I was gonna wait
to play it on the PS five right because
typically they have like a definitive
edition but I've heard that they're not
gonna do that and then possibly they'll
just put it on PC instead that's that
was something I was gonna bring up the
whole entire rumor of everything from
yes a Playstation go into PC I am
ecstatic because like I'm like I want to
play horizon zero dawn I want to play
spider-man I want to play Last of Us I
want to play all these amazing
PlayStation games but I don't know
station because I'm not gonna like I
don't wanna my time frame of playing
games is consists of Monday to Friday
from 7:00 to 10:00 that is my time frame
of one I can play my games for the most
part so I have to be selective and I'm
not gonna buy a console and I probably
won't buy an xbox this gen because like
I don't have time like I literally
bought an Xbox and I haven't even really
touched it like well you're not gonna
have to you you know exactly what cross
playing stuff that's I was gonna say ii
would call ddr super happy with the
crossfade cross play capabilities i mean
the game
not without its issues but right
cross-play is a game changer yes it is
it's gonna be great uh tire King
actually is leaving you a message el and
shot do you want to read that out yeah
just stopped by to say have a great team
maybe stream Happy Holidays Happy New
Year in El Bulli old school and women in
g WG are awesome wishing everyone great
things in 2020 take care thank you
talking he's what a couple of contests
from those oh very nice and thanks thank
you are given so you know the the the
love and the support you know we
appreciate you doing that for
right so well if you if you have
anything else we're gonna say no no MJ
what about you man what about next year
for you you looking forward to anything
there sure cyberpunk yeah and what was
the other one you said we could barely
understand her maternal to maternal yeah
and I played a little bit of watchdogs
at e3 yeah it was okay yeah I just be
careful what you say you might be under
NDA with that I don't know I don't know
how much NDA you're in there for watch
those say no Ubisoft makes you like NDA
up the ying-yang yeah but yeah Sarah so
so you're looking forward to a plane
watch so here's cyberpunk and Jim
eternal so anything else you kind of saw
that you kind of feature interests um
[Music]
minecraft dungeons what are they doing
with that they just adding dungeons to
the Minecraft universe it's like a
single-player game there it's online
yeah you can see it they got a
single-player game yeah well you're the
person that I want I love watching you
play see if these it's always
interesting with Ellis like see to see
if these yeah I need to play more
[Music]
yeah with you actually we could we could
doesn't need we could do it before the
show if we wanted to right I'll do PC is
it anything anything else you it you're
thinking about nope nope next year for
me I am actually looking forward to to a
couple of different stuff I'm looking
forward to seeing what division 2 is
gonna do to kind of revitalize the game
kind of be keeping an eye on that as
always because I'm huge division 2 fan
I'm looking forward to seeing what
Destiny's doing and warframe has been
doing because they've been adding a lot
of new contents into those two games
also so I've been keeping an eye on them
and seeing what's happening so that
stuff's gonna be really interesting I
think
cyberpunk I I want to play it but I
don't know how long it's gonna be and I
don't know if I'm gonna have the time to
designate to it yeah yeah that's what I
had a feeling I had a feeling this could
be like The Witcher oh by the way
Witcher there's gonna come out tomorrow
watch the last episode of Watchmen
tonight
yeah I think I can butcher comes out
tomorrow and then Star Wars comes out on
Wednesday the Mandalorian comes out
Wednesday and no I have not watched it
I'm still trying to catch up with my
pops still trying to do that so yeah so
that's coming out and then they got Star
Wars coming out this week and then the
last episode of the Mandalorian also is
coming up yeah so what's called and then
the like cyberpunk I'm kind of excited
to see I'm excited to see what they're
gonna do with Bioshock there's been
rumors of an of a new game coming out so
I'm kind of excited to get and see it
and see that kind of excited also to see
what they're gonna end up doing with
well like with World of Warcraft's how
they're gonna try to pull that out of
the dumpster fire that it is
that nobody loves because they got that
new game coming out this they speak
other than this week I'm sorry next year
so there was saying like right before
summertime probably we're gonna end up
seeing that so there's a couple of PC
games I'm probably gonna be sticking
mostly with with escape from tarkov
firfer for a little bit just because
it's got my it's got my teeth in it and
it's so good that's all
okay I can't stop wanting to play it but
yeah I mean that's that's all I really
am looking forward to like I said I'm
probably not gonna pick up the Xbox or
the PlayStation 5 I may I might try to
go to e3 if time and money allows it and
definitely you want to PAX East make
sure to so yeah that's that's it's all
from me is there is there anything else
so you guys are kind of interested in
for the next upcoming year nope no well
yeah I mean how are you guys complaining
are not improving your streams or doing
anything with that I want to like get
more animations going um like pop ups in
the middle your stream like if you'd if
someone says something in chat something
happens right yeah yeah I'd like to do
more that do some more interactive stuff
and try to play more variety I guess
well you you you prefer to be a more of
a variety streamer yeah I like to play
whatever like yeah whatever it makes you
happy yeah yeah what about what about
you MJ so for me maybe start streaming
again yeah I think you think schools
gonna be able to allow you to do it um I
don't know next semester classes are
gonna be a lot harder I don't know yeah
well hopefully yeah hopefully you know
you're able to make it more for the for
the podcast next year yeah
we love you we love your input and your
you know your insight if you will so uh
oh I'm sorry I thought I think I cut you
off were you gonna say anything else
before No so for me next year I'm going
to I'm just looking to make it more of a
for my streams at least to make them
more interactive so people are able to
you know come want to come back I want
to say hello want to do things they try
to do a little bit more in-game
giveaways for games I'm playing that's
that's what I think I'm gonna try to aim
towards you know that's because I you
know I want to give back to the people
that are watching so and I want to
finish you know making a nice little
merch corner to to you know so if people
want to support the stream and it kind
of like what they see what's happening
like mmm excuse me like we have a look
of a couple of things that I have I want
to I have like are my logo and I have
you know a couple of the characters and
things like that and I'm trying to do
that type of stuff so that's that's and
try to keep with my schedule because the
schedules been working actually pretty
nice eh I've just been seeing continuous
growth for the past six monsters just
which is nice which has been good so
that's that's my aim all right well
there's there's nothing else going on I
think think when we do or when we do our
outros MJ do you want to start um you
can find me on a mixer at beat ten you
can find me on twitch MJ as a boss same
thing with Twitter
MJ as a boss and snapchat is a beat ten
the snapchat king coming here coming to
you or snapchat for 4000 snapchats no
four hundred thousand four hundred
thousand yeah your mind man five years
dude so we're gonna work next year next
year I'm gonna give you a plan for round
table so you see so you could take care
of some some more of our marketing stuff
I'm give it to you give you
responsibilities that's cog would say so
yes and L what about you Lu Soler my bad
you hear me yeah you can find me Oh
buddy Oh 208 on Twitter and on mixer and
yeah I'm pretty much doing
afternoon/evening strings I should get
more consistent after my mom goes home
and yeah yes and please if you are
listening to this make sure you go to
those channels make sure you give LA
follow you know she wants to hit that
goal of a thousand followers by the end
of the end of the year so yes yes sure I
didn't think I was gonna get this close
yes so please follow her please support
her we love it we love RL and this meets
now though SN al why do i am on twitter
i am on twitch I am on discord I am on
all those fun things so yes please be
sure you follow and everything they're
so good yeah that's pretty much it if
you have any questions or anything Paul
means it yeah you know this is where
we're gonna be we're gonna be taking a
break now from now until January 6th we
actually have our art guests I'll swear
it away and ready for for then so we're
gonna be you know we're gonna be trying
to refine what are the podcast is for us
and we're gonna be ending up excuse me
we're gonna end up making sure stuff is
all good while we're on break I'm gonna
make sure it's do rejuvenate ourselves
some holiday stuff I will actually be on
ILP this week with the guys on
on Sunday if you still want to hear me
jibber jabber about random stuff and the
guys are gonna be there like a like I
would say Wednesday we're gonna be going
up on iTunes so go ahead over there and
you can listen to us there
Spotify all those funds things follow us
on on Twitter it's table streams so you
can hear when we're gonna go live so
that you can see us and know what our
next guest is going to be we pretty much
just post who the guest is going to be
you know if Anton's going on and
communications for for some for some
other podcasts there so yes in youtube
we should be good very shortly after
that once we're done here and thank you
very much if you have any questions or
for our guests please email around table
stream team at gmail comm iron Lords
podcast is Sunday at 11 a.m. Eastern I
think this is our last week at that time
and then after that we're gonna be going
to our later time frame so check us out
on Lord of gaming Lords wow I know just
totally fumbled in my mouth Lords of
gaming net where we have a lot of our
gaming news and things like that please
go check us out there great group of
guys there and remember everyone to
dream big and keep gaming thank you very
much for a fantastic half a year
everybody for coming following us
hanging out talking with us and chat I
can't tell you how much I appreciate you
guys my chat actually has broke so I
don't know if anyone has said anything
since Tiger King but thank you all for
being there and thank you for hitting
those like buttons for us and we will
see everybody on January 6th I think
that's the Monday so thanks again
everybody and have a fantastic holiday
and happy New Year to everyone alright
bye everybody